thanks for having me today i'd like to
talk to you about
something that's
been of my interest for the last few
years which is the use of multiplexing
immunostore chemicals staining in
immunofluorescence
both when it comes to using this in
clinical practice and also research and
these are two areas which are moving
closer and closer together so i think
now is the time to ask ourselves the
question
can we actually introduce this
multiplexing technique into our daily
clinical practice and help us in making
the pathological diagnosis
sas has been introduced i'm a thoracic
pathologist in in rotterdam so i deal
with both oncological thoracic pathology
and non-oncological thoracic pathology
and i think both would actually to some
extent already benefit from the
introduction of multiplex
immunohistochemistry and
immunofluorescence in clinical practice
and like routine diagnosis
these are my disclosures
so if we think about multiplexing
methods i think we can define them as
anything that can simultaneously
demonstrate the presence of proteins in
tissue
up from three markers to now up to 100
markers in the same slide
of course there are different levels of
complexity and there are also many
different methods of actually achieving
this
so classically when we look at the
techniques which can be used to sustain
many markers at the same time we can
look at fluorescence-based methods which
are here depicted at the top which can
deal with
the ffp material that we routinely use
in diagnostics also frozen material or
perhaps even adherent cells in cell
culture
and by using a secondary antibody you
can actually visualize the the binding
of the primary antibody and use a
fluorescent tag to then visualize under
the respective microscope this can also
be done by using an antibody which is
conjugated to oligonucleotides and
achieving very much the same sort of
image but in that case you could use up
to more than 50 biomarkers at the same
time
so another technique to actually achieve
this high multiplexing or high number
multiplexing technique would be mass
spectrometry based methods which could
be site of imaging mass cytometry or
multiplexed ion beam type imaging uh and
all of these techniques actually
described in this very interesting paper
which gives a very nice review of all of
these different approaches to
multiplexing
these are then conjugated with metal
isotopes in both cases
and
by using the site of technology you can
then image those in one slide with
sometimes a slightly less
in the way of resolution than the
classical immunofluorescence techniques
something which is written over the
recent few years is also in
multiplexing using chromogenic methods
you can either do that by stain erasing
so you stain a slide then image the
slide and then bleach the slide again
and then stain again with a new antibody
and then building up uh this picture of
the slide over the various different
stain cycles
you could also do that and this is
something that we've been using over the
last couple of years
by using different antibodies with hrp
and then
then
staining with different chromogens
but with a heat deactivation step in
between so you can actually build up a
single uh picture of
one slide without the need for imaging
in between
using these techniques you can not
achieve the sort of
highly high numerical
multiplexing techniques that you can
with multiplex iron beam imaging or with
imaging mass cytometry
where multiplex ion beam
is based on the technique where you can
actually shine
an ion beam onto these metal labels of
antibodies which you can see here on the
left
and then by detecting them by an iron
detector or a time of flight detector
you can build up
a picture of per uh surface area of all
the various metals which are present and
then build up the picture as you go
along the slide
imaging mass cytometry is slightly
different in that you use laser ablation
you basically burn off all of the
antibody including
the metal ions and then again by time of
flight you can detect
these and build up a similar picture in
very much the same way
now all of these techniques uh have
their advantages and drawbacks and again
these are very nicely depicted in in
this paper i won't go through all of
them suffice to say that as i already
alluded to
the multiplexed immunist chemical
technique um is in our hands as we're
used to these types of techniques and
antibodies
a very practical method
but unfortunately it doesn't allow
to use more than five to ten labeled
antibodies per slide depending on the
technique you use
whereas on the other end of the spectrum
using the mass cytometry and type
approaches you can use up to
more than 50 antibodies at a time
but this tends to be quite
difficult
for a routine laboratory it's not a
routine technique to use
it tends to be expensive and sometimes
you're also limited
by the field of view of this technique
or the area of interest that you can
actually investigate so i think these
techniques while they're very
interesting for an exploratory setting
at the moment are probably
not the most
advantageous to use in a routine
diagnostic setting
then there are some common multiplex
immuno techniques and platforms which
will also be discussed today so for
instance a milan technique where you can
use up to 30 different staining scanning
and stripping cycles reaching up to more
than 100 antibodies for a particular
staining
procedure
something that we also have in-house is
the nanostring duamax digital spatial
profiling
platform using fluorescent tags with up
to 96 targets
uh based on imaging mass cytometry is
the hyperian system um with four to 37
protein markers and something that i'm
sure is also going to be discussed today
is the opal chemistry and spectron
mixing that you can do with that and
with up to seven targets something that
we've been using mainly in our routine
uh diagnostic setting is a rush
discovery system where we use sequential
heaty activated chromogenic staining
in which case we're actually limited to
a five-plex stain
so for all of these different techniques
i think it's important to not forget
that these are of course
combinations of individual stains so
it's always important to actually go
through a process of validation of the
various antibodies which are then
eventually included
to come to the multiplexing imaging and
by using them in a single text approach
to see whether they actually perform as
well as you would expect from any single
plex stain so that's something that goes
for all of these different techniques
so why would we be interested in
multiplex immunotechniques in routine
diagnostic pathology well i think one of
the main purposes could be an ease of
use case or a convenience of using
different types of stains in in one
slide
this could be
reciprocal staining patterns or perhaps
complementary staining patterns we'll
see that in that in a second
um something else
that could be interesting would be to
use these methods
in a setting where we have very little
material available
and increasingly with this very little
material we also have to do molecular
techniques so be very useful for tissue
preservation if you only needed one
section to do this stain on rather than
multiple sections as we routinely do at
the moment that's important for the
tissue stewardship role that we also
have as pathologists
make sure that we use it in the most
correct manner
and something else that we could do with
multiplexing would be layered analysis
where you stay in a particular
population of cells and then look for
expression of a particular other target
within that specific population these
are sometimes very difficult to identify
just by the morphology alone something
that we'll have a look at
spatial information in one slide can be
very important and can hold a lot of
information
as to for instance the invasive pattern
of various cancers
by combining different stains we can do
cellular sub-phenotyping
in a
single slide that's also
very interesting particularly also
for instance for our hemato pathological
colleagues who then don't need to look
at different levels and then try to
combine the various
stains into one
phenotype
increasingly we could also use various
different stains to molecularly
characterize a tumor if we know what the
underlying potential molecular
alteration is
and something that undoubtedly today
will also be discussed is the analysis
of complex cellular interactions and
infiltration particularly in the context
of immune oncology
and that will also require automated
quantification and deep learning
approaches which is something that i'll
only just briefly touch upon and which i
no doubt will also be discussed today in
later talks
so for a very uh simple ease of use case
we can look at something that has had
the attention of our laboratory which is
oral dysplasia uh in which um patients
who have a normally
developing
oral
surface
epithelial surface will have a normal
expression
of these cytokeratines
whereas if you then
have
different degrees of uh dysplasia you
can see that there's an increase in the
expression of uh ck14 so if you combine
those two you actually have a very nice
resi
reciprocal pattern
and you can make an estimate as to
whether this is actually a true
phenotype because you have that
additional information in that single
slide
that is actually important because if
you have a
a surface area which does not display
any morphological
dysplasia and it is also positive for
ck13 that has a very good
prognosis
whereas
if you have a patient
who does not display obvious dysplasia
but you have loss of ck13 the prognosis
is worse so this is actually something
that has important prognostic uh
implications and you can actually
integrate that into this flow scheme
where you can
include the ck13 staining into your
decision entry as to whether these
patients should be followed up or you
could dei intensify the follow-up
something very similar can also be done
in the context of vulva intraepithelial
neoplasia where also you can combine
these co 13 stains or ck17 stains with
for instance proliferation markers such
as mib1
providing additional information
something that as a thoracic pathologist
has my particular interest is tissue
preservation in the context of small
biopsies or cytology of lung cancer
because nowadays we have to do quite a
few tests to actually provide a
predictive profile for these tumors so
if you are dealing with a squamous
carcinoma
you can sometimes get away with just
doing a pdl-1 stain to see whether these
patients actually qualify for immune
oncology or whether they are treated by
chemotherapy alone
sometimes
in never or light smokers or younger
patients you may also want to add
additional molecular uh profiling which
is routine in fact in the non-squamous
cell carcinoma so
there are there's an increasing list of
different predictive markers that we
need to
ascertain in these often very small
biopsies and that's based for instance
in the case of pdl1 now on quite a large
a number of different clinical studies
which have proven the efficacy of pdl1
as a predictive marker for immunotherapy
so the tissue preservation protocol
prescribes that you try to do as little
as possible prior to doing all this
predictive testing
and that would
also include the use of immunochemical
markers which you need to identify the
different subtypes of non
non small cell carcinoma that we know in
clinical practice so the
squamous cell carcinoma versus the non
squamous mainly
and routinely we would do that by a
single humanistic chemical stains
however that's also possible to combine
uh in a multiplexing technique for
instance in this case we have a
psychological preparation here on the
left in the h e stain on the right you
can see that ttf1
stains the nuclei and then napsin
stains the cytoplasm of this
adenocarcinoma of the lung so that's
something that we routinely use
admittedly these are of course only two
markers at the
moment
you can also do that in small biopsies
with very much the same results so here
you can confirm that's an adenocarcinoma
up along without having to do two
separate stains you can add in a
different stain to that
to see whether you can actually also
exclude
any squamous cell
differentiation
so something something else that's
interesting to us when it comes to using
multiplexing in the routine setting
would be layered analysis so in this
case for instance we're interested in
the proliferation rate of the epithelium
in this slide and not so much the
proliferation which is happening outside
of the epithelium so here you can see uh
in red the uh pan keratin stain whereas
in
the brown you can see the ki-67 stain
so that would be much easier to actually
interpret and do the counting of these
stains something that we've also used in
layered analysis
is
the analysis of a
a lymph node in this very topical case
of a covid19 patient who by using the h
and e was
suspicious of having had a
lymphohystocytosis and here we used a
multiplexing technique where we used a
cd68
and
in this case there's cd3 stain in the
middle uh at the bottom and a uh an mpo
stain in blue
at the right uh bottom
picture here where we can see that you
can see inclusion of both t cells
and granulocytes in these macrophages
and thereby proving that in fact we're
dealing with this hla
type
disorder in covent 19 in this case
going back to immuno oncology you can
also appreciate here by just using the
pdl1 stain in non-small cell lung cancer
on the on the left which is staining the
the epithelial cells but in a in a
different patient the epithelial cells
are actually negative but the
macrophages are positive and by
morphology alone particularly
to somebody who's not used to looking at
uh non-small cell lung cancer sections
this may be very difficult to
distinguish
so it would be good if we could actually
combine pdl-1 staining with for instance
here on the right in pink the ttf1 stain
and also in yellow
the pan keratin stain so here we can see
by using this multiplex approach with
these three different stains of pdl-1
and
also the keratin and ttf1 but this is
tumor
and this in fact
is an area of immune cell filtration
which by using pdl-1 alone is very
difficult to distinguish
so this is a potential application which
i think we'll see more and more of in
the years to come
of course it would be ideal to also
combine
the pan keratin stain with a pdl-1 and
macrophage stain in one single
multiplex method and that's been shown
here
so you can actually determine which
cells
are tumor cells and which cells are
macrophages in just a single slide and
that is also something that can then be
used for automated uh digital analysis
so in this particular biopsy you can see
that there's just a small glandular
structure which may be only present in
one particular section so if you do
another section that may be actually cut
out of this tissue so it would be very
useful to actually do this particular
multiplex stain on that single section
to determine that this is in fact an
invasive
glandular structure as opposed to the
ones which are
close to it which have this intact basal
epithelial layer
you could also combine different stains
to do cellular sub phenotyping in situ
in
slides where here for instance
these cells were stained with cd3 which
of course denotes t lymphocytes but also
with cd8 which points towards a
cytotoxic phenotype and cd4 which is a t
helper cell phenotype and then combining
those you can actually define these
different populations by combining the
different stains
now this is a case where we use this
type of cellulose of phenotyping so this
is a 58 year old male with
lymphadenopathy of unknown origin
and who on a previous ebis diagnosis was
shown to have atypical cells which were
suggestive for non-small cell lung
carcinoma
then
the clinicians apparently were unsure as
to how true to treat those patients and
luckily they decided to do a
mediocenoscopy and removed lymph nodes
for analysis that showed
the following picture in the h e stain
where we can see that there's an
extensive infiltrate of
small lymphocytes and there's quite a
lot of sclerosis there's the odd used in
the fill
and if you see this sort of picture
particularly if there are some larger
cells in this
infiltrate you might suggest that this
could potentially be a hodgkin lymphoma
but of course that needs to be confirmed
then a cd20 stain was done showing an
infiltrate infiltrator b lymphocytes and
perhaps a few larger cells cd30 didn't
show that much in the way of staining
and the cells were not obviously
atypical and not enlarged
cd15 did show a few larger cells with
also a paranuclear dot that's already
suspicious and then pax 5 which might
also stain
hodgkin's cells was also positive in
some of the larger cells but was not
particularly convincing
interestingly there was also positivity
for ebv so we couldn't reach a certain
diagnosis and then
we decided to use a
multiplex immunostain
including cd15 cd20 and cd30 where cd20
is showing all of these pink cells and
then
cd15 that's the yellow yellow stain and
cd30 is the green stain surrounding them
you can actually see that cd30 and cd15
co-localize very nicely in these cells
which were then
shown to be hodgkin's cells whereas the
surrounding cd20 positive cells
are reactive b cells so we can actually
make a confidence diagnosis of a
classical non-hodgkin lymphoma in a
minutes amount of material in this case
you could also use multiplexing for
molecular characterization and this is a
case of a cerebral
tumor a 53 year old female who had a
left occipital tumor
suspicious for a glioblastoma multiforme
potentially metastasis
molecular diagnosis was done it was
actually diagnosed as a glyphostoma
and then the molecular diagnosis
diagnostic tests showed a p53 mutation
nf1 and a
variant of unknown significance in nf1
and the complex chromosomal loss
with mgmt promoter methylation
and it is known that
these tumors with a hypermutated genome
sometimes have mmr also mismatched
repair deficiency
and
might benefit from
microsatellite stability analysis
because they do not respond to certain
types of treatment which need
proficient mmr tumors to actually be
effective
so you could actually then in this tumor
do
staining and this is the h e slide
staining for these various mmr proteins
as you would also normally do for
instance in colon carcinoma if that's
indicated for instance for mlh1 and pms2
where you can see that in this tumor
these were still present
but then doing the msh2 stain and
msh16 you can see that some of the cells
do not stay but it this provides you a
very complex picture you don't really
know
which are the tumor cells which are the
stromal cells in this case
these tumor cells were also positive for
p53 but we don't know whether that
overlaps with
the uh
the mismatched repair protein stains
so we then decided to again multiplex
and use
msh2 which is seen here in in purple
and p53 in yellow so you see quite a few
cells uh only have the p53 in the
nucleus and they're lacking msh2 because
if they combine you actually see that
these cells show up as red cells so by
doing that you can actually show that
the tumor cells which are p53 positive
are also the ones which lack msh2
so i've already
alluded to immuno oncology a few times
so we're used to just looking for the
absence of checkpoints to predict
behavior of particular tumor to
immunotherapy in non-small cell lung
cancer increasingly it's also known that
intra-tumor
t-cells may play a role
so if you haven't got any t-cells the
tumors unlikely to respond maybe you
might also need to look at
tumor sensitivity or immune effects such
as ms mhc expression
and also potentially to look at
mutational load as a surrogate markup
for tumor foreigners and we've
combined
these approaches in some of the studies
that we've done and this is a different
paper in which uh in fact these authors
looked at a meta-analysis of these
various techniques
as a standalone and it was seen uh that
by using uh the multiplex
immunochemistry
uh approach you can actually achieve a
very good area under the curve with a
very good uh positive and negative
predictive value so this actually uh
outperforms some of the uh the more
classical markers that we know which are
predictive for
response to immunotherapy and by
combining all of these you can actually
achieve a very good
pool specificity
so you can do that by looking at all
these
components in isolation so for instance
looking at exclusion of cd8 cells again
by using multiplex techniques
and we've also done this
in
small biopsy specimens and a
retrospective study
in which we looked at various parameters
in isolation
so we found that patients who had a very
low pdl1 low cd8 infiltration low hla
expression
and
also a high html
in this case
do quite badly whereas if you have a
high tml
and a high pdl1 expression high cd8
expression and presence of hla
you tend to respond better to
immunotherapy
and that is borne out
by
doing the separate analysis for pdl1
both for uh progression-free survive on
overall survival
cd8 is not so predictive an hla loss by
itself is also not predictive
but if you combine all of those and you
do unsupervised clustering you can
actually see
that by
combining all of these positive
phenotypes you can see that these
patients have the best survival both
when it comes to progression-free and
overall survival
and of course it would be great if we
could combine all of those markers into
a single multiplex image and that's what
we've recently done by using pdo1
cytokeratin as well as cd8 and
and markers for immune cells
you can then deconvolute this this slide
uh do
additional analysis on this and actually
look for nearest neighbor analysis for
instance and co-localization and then
combining all of those you have
at least as good a predictive value of
response immunotherapy as when you
combine all of those after having done
single plex stains so something that
somebody else will talk about today is
automated quantification and deep
learning that's necessary for analysis
of some of these very complex
combined
stains you can use that to segment
different
types of cells to classify different
areas
or
different cellular compositions
to quantify of course
the various different components that
you're interested in but also to do more
complex analysis such as nearest
neighbor analysis or proximity analysis
or infiltration analysis and uh
eventually also by doing this in an uh
unsupervised way you could use it for
exploratory analysis and actually find
out whether there are additional
parameters which might be predictive for
a specific response to therapy and there
are many approaches to this which i will
not go into at the moment many platforms
and software packages that one could use
so for instance here we've we see a
slide of a lung cancer where we've
stained the answer for keratin in red
and uh for uh ki 67 in uh brown
and then doing this type of analysis we
can actually create a sort of a heat map
of tumor
and proliferative activity which can be
used in the setting that we used it for
for correlation with pet ct images
so that's a way to do the analysis
um
here are
the other types of analysis as i
quickly mentioned so this is uh the uh
classifier analysis where you can
actually distinguish different areas of
the tumor you can do this nearest
neighbor analysis or to look for
differences or to look for distances
between different immune cells and a
tumor for instance which is also done
here and you can look for infiltration
of the tumor by immune cells by doing
this type of deep learning approach and
then hopefully eventually you could
combine all of those approaches and then
come up with a predictive model
to classify this tumor with
now to finish off
i think it's important that all of these
steps require of course uh rigid
validation
so
the pre-processing phase is important
you know how long do you keep the tissue
on full line for for instance uh then
the process itself its
stage itself is important of course to
validate the staining procedure
the analytical phase
and then eventually also
the ai
algorithms which are trained using all
of these images so all of these need to
be validated uh in your own uh
laboratory uh both on that from a
technical point of view uh internally
but also potentially also eventually
externally uh you also have to validate
it against the singleplex staining as i
mentioned earlier so you need to be sure
that what you're looking at in multiplex
is actually a true representation of the
multiple single flex staining
you also have to perhaps think about
validating it against the pathologist
assessment so if you're using these ai
approaches
you need to be sure that if you're going
to use that in a diagnostic setting it's
at least as good as a pathologist in
doing the same sort of assessment
then you have to make sure if you
do that type of
analysis that the staining consistency
is right that you
have a good scanner with the right
magnification which is consistent as
well you have to choose the right
analytical software which it can produce
with consistent results
the settings are important how big are
the areas of interest that you look at
for instance
what type of algorithm do you use so
these are all steps that you need to
make decisions about and which can have
implications for use of
this type of approach in a routine
setting further on
and then
last but not least
i think we all require prognostic and
predictive validation so in in true uh
patient cohorts this can be done in a
retrospective or a prospective manner
because eventually what counts is that
what we do actually has a bearing on the
prognosis or prediction for this
individual patient
uh and then
of course also nowadays we need to make
sure that everything that we do
can be integrated into our routine
workflow is it easy to use
for instance in our pac system other
efficiency gains for the laboratory or
the pathologists
so by doing all this and as as i've
described in
all of the previous slides i think we
can now move from an area
in which an era sorry in which we were
focused on finding that one black sheep
in the sea of white sheep to
an era in which we want to identify all
of these colorful sheep uh in one single
photograph uh and as we're moving along
this uh development i think more and
more we can see that this is actually
almost ready for clinical practice
although i think that will be in the
context of probably uh the lower end of
the number of uh multiplex uh stains
that you use and rather than those sort
of more exploratory analyses um with
the scores of different
antibodies that can be used for instance
in uh these site of type approaches
so that's almost as colorful as our uh
skyline at night in rotterdam and i'd
like to thank you for listening and i'm
happy to answer questions